github co-pilot is now available to all
developers while a big open source
community is leaving it behind but not
only github but also google and amazon
are jumping into the game of ai assisted
source code generation welcome to ml
news
[Music]
welcome to mmo news today we talk all
about models that generate source code
and that assists developers in writing
source code the github blog released a
post last month saying github copilot is
generally available to all developers
copilot is obviously the product by
github based on openai's codex model
that suggests source code completions to
you based on a large language model
that's been trained on all of public
github repositories this is i have to
say a really cool product i was part of
the closed beta and it was a game
changer especially if you write any sort
of boilerplate code this thing will just
write an entire function for you it will
write your tests it will write your doc
strings it will write your assertions
and your error messages it's just very
very good for a specific subset of
programming but nevertheless that subset
is making a lot of difference in a lot
of people's lives so the product now is
out of this beta and is available to all
developers for a price so it's 10 bucks
a month or a hundred a year which i feel
is reasonable if you are a programmer by
profession this thing is potentially
going to make you a lot more productive
than the 10 bucks a month it is free for
verified open source projects and for
verified students now this is ai news
and not necessarily and not always ai
shilling so github has not been without
controversy obviously we have reported
on this github has been trained on a lot
of code including open source code
including code that has been licensed
under various copy left licenses with
the intention that whatever products are
made from that code are also free and
available to the community these
copyleft licenses such as the gpl are
specifically made such that no company
can just grab that code and then resell
it as a product because it's based on
the work of a lot of unpaid volunteers
essentially copilot is doing exactly
that it's taking a lot of code that's
publicly accessible yet licensed under
such licenses taking it in training a
large language model on it and then
selling that to you as a product now
this is a legal gray area for example
you as a programmer are perfectly
entitled to go look at a piece of code
even if it's under the gpl and learn
from that piece of code and then
implement that same algorithm in your
own way in your own code that is not a
violation of copyright it's a different
story if that algorithm is patented but
in terms of copyright and copy left
you're perfectly fine doing that so it's
perfectly reasonable to say that
training a large language model on that
code that then sort of takes bits and
pieces learns from it and then
synthesizes its own version from what it
learned is a lot like a human doing that
same thing however obviously it's being
automated and it being you know cranked
up to 11 in size and speed and then
being sold to all the developers out
there might be a different story and
that's why the register writes open
source body quits github urges you to do
the same this article is about the
software freedom conservancy this is a
non-profit focused on free and open
source software and they are arguing
that github is essentially using your
work to build its own proprietary system
namely github copilot and github itself
remember the source code of the github
website isn't public so your work as an
open source developer essentially goes
into github as a product and that's
exactly what a lot of these open source
people don't want so the software
freedom conservancy has released a blog
post called give up github the time has
come in which they detail that not only
they are leaving github but they tell
you to do the same and they are
announcing a plan and support structures
from them to support people to get away
from github and to move to more
open source friendly alternatives
specifically obviously the biggest
impact is going to make to move the
source code hosting away from github to
some other place be that either a
cloud-hosted provider or a self-hosted
something now while i recognize that the
idea kinda makes sense if those things
are important to you it seems like a bit
useless and pointless like just as no
license is stopping github from scraping
its own repositories if you put your
source code on your website nothing's
stopping github from just scraping that
it's the same deal a human is allowed to
look at it learn from it and then
re-implement it so is a language model
at least for now so it seems like the
real path forward here would be a legal
one in which there could be a license
that explicitly states that no training
on this data of any sort is allowed
which essentially might amount to just a
patent but i don't know i'm not a lawyer
so i don't know what can even be done in
these kinds of situations and the
boundaries between humans and language
models and code assist and whatnot yet
extremely murky copilot is an insanely
useful product and github has been a
absolutely great place for most of open
source in the last many many years and
obviously as with a lot of free products
there's got to be a way to make some
money around that now sure there are
various business models around open
source but i'd rather pay for co-pilot
than seeing an ad every time i want to
clone a git repo so there are a lot of
questions in the air right here what's
also interesting is that they give you
this snippet that they encourage you to
put into your readme if you can't move
away from github just now saying we are
using github under protest this project
is currently hosted on github we are
deeply concerned about using a
proprietary system like github to
develop our foss project any use of this
project's code by github copilot past or
present is done without our permission
we do not consent to github's views of
this project's code in copilot yeah it's
about as effective as the
if you are not the intended recipient of
this message delete this email right now
it does nothing and it's obviously there
to raise awareness but still i don't see
how even moving away from github will
solve the larger issues around this
topic but let me know what you think in
the comments be happy to hear your
opinions
google released a blog post called ml
enhanced code completion improves
developer productivity this is about an
internal study that they have done where
they augmented their own code completion
engine which is based on very classical
code completion such as what variable
names exist what functions exist yada
yada and they augmented that with ml
based code completion such as copilot so
they experimented with various flavors
such as single line completion
multi-line completion or simply ranking
the outputs of the semantic engine that
they already had by using a machine
learning model this all is based on a
language model architecture notably it
only has 0.5 billion parameters so a
tiny model in current standards but they
say this is due to latency requirements
so that makes a lot of sense google has
deployed this internally to their
developers and have found a great
increase in efficiency of programming
compared to a control group now while
it's really cool that a big company can
just run these experiments internally on
their people it must suck to be in the
control room for one of these like this
is the latest and greatest tech and you
know your company internally only has
access to it and then you're like bam
you're in the control group i'm sorry
for you control groupers i hope you get
access soon so this blog post here
claims that just under three percent of
all new code that's added to the google
code base is code that has been accepted
by recommendation from a machine
learning engine there's a six percent
reduction in coding iteration duration
there's a seven percent reduction in
context switches such as moving away
from the ide to go look something up and
they have about a 25
acceptance rate which is how often a
suggestion pops up versus how often you
accept that suggestion these numbers
look a little bit different for
multi-line suggestions but still very
encouraging now while this is really
cool as i said it's only available
google internally currently it also has
been trained on their internal code base
which is huge we're left to see whether
or not that or something like this is
going to be available to the general
public anytime soon as we saw with
copilot there is definitely money to be
made with ml supported code completion
but google might just be happy with the
increase in productivity of their own
workforce and that's going to make them
a lot of money by itself
there's a new paper called language
models can teach themselves to program
better now this is a little bit
different from code completion as it
deals with programming puzzles
specifically programming puzzles that
are formulated as tests in programming
languages so the general structure is
that the problem is posed as a function
f that takes one parameter and checks
the validity of that parameter somehow
you can specify a lot of things as
taking a solution and then verifying it
i mean i guess you can specify any sort
of problem in that way and then the
solution to that would be a function
called g right here g gets access to the
source code of f and is then supposed to
write code that returns something that's
then fed into f that's gonna make f true
a bit more complicated example is down
here so f will accept an x and check if
that x is a palindrome now there can be
more arguments right here for example
the length of that palindrome and g does
get access to these arguments as well
but still the same principle g is going
to get access to the source code of f it
can analyze it as much as it wants and
then has to come up with its own source
code that makes f go true so the problem
f here is in fact the finding of a
palindrome with exactly n copies of each
of a given list of substring and so you
can see right here that the solution is
you simply take n of each you join them
and then you add the reverse to it i
guess that wouldn't work if either of
the arguments here are themselves a
palindrome because then technically that
string would also appear in that part
right here or if like the cross here
like the cross boundary well you see it
gets arbitrarily complex but you get the
point these are illustrative examples so
there is a training set but it only
contains 155 puzzles authored by humans
and the trick here is that not only use
ai to solve these puzzles but you
actually use it to generate more of them
so we have lots of open source models
and closed source models such as codex
that can generate source code that are
pre-trained on source code so the paper
prompts these models with a bunch of
prefixes from the training set so here
you see that's just the problems not the
solutions and then the models are tasked
to come up with more problems the next
step you use the same language models or
different ones to actually solve those
generated problems and you give them a
bit of time so they can explore a bunch
of options which you can automatically
verify now that leaves you with a large
set of automatically created but
programmatically verified synthetic
puzzles on which you can then fine-tune
that language model and start from the
top so you can use the same language
model potentially multiple times to come
up with new problems new solutions to
them verify all of that and then retrain
these models again now as far as i
understand the paper only does one cycle
of this and already observes a huge
boost especially on the verified
examples so when they make sure that the
generated problems and solutions
actually you know match and work and
return true in that case there seems to
be a big boost if you retrain these
language models so you can see right
here a variant of gpt neo solves only
about 7.5
of the test puzzles when just tasked
like that but if you go through all of
these steps it solves 38.2 of all these
puzzles now there are several issues
right here obviously information
theoretically you can't just conjure out
information out of nothing so whatever
these models know you know you
essentially just feed that back to them
with the step in between actually
verifying the code but given that
they've been trained on public code and
a lot of that presumably runs especially
if it's kind of filtered for more higher
quality training data then that check
shouldn't be too much of a barrier so it
seems like if we just prompted these
models better we could probably get them
to solve a lot more of these programming
puzzles since the knowledge seems to be
somewhere in there and also there's the
other issue that these programming
puzzles you know humans came up with
them and so on they might not be on
github themselves so deduplication is
obviously necessary but deduplication
might not be enough as kind of like the
solutions to the problems themselves
might be in some way somewhere on github
it's like in the training data of these
models and that way if you just prompt
them in that direction there might be
some effect right there i don't know but
it is definitely a cool result and it
seems like if we can pair these models
correctly prompt them correctly and then
use additional resources such as these
external verification procedure in order
to enhance the training data in order to
just just make it better less noisy more
to the point of what we want that could
be a good way forward to get these large
models to do what we want and it might
be an alternative to coming up with
smart prompts that just kind of work
somehow like the uh let's think about it
step-by-step trick like it would be nice
if we had a more systematic way of
getting these models to do what we want
and i think this paper is a step in that
direction
okay so amazon joins the ring of ml
powered code completion with its code
whisper product now much like copilot
this is a model that generates source
code and you can subscribe to it it
integrates with your ide and then you
can try it out you can let it complete
source code and suggest stuff now it's a
little bit different in that they not
only want to do completion but they also
claim to do security scans in your code
and it's apparently specifically good at
interacting with aws apis they claim
it's trained on open source code but
also on amazon internal code now for now
this product is closed there's a wait
list you can put your name on there no
guarantee but it's interesting to see
that yet another company is sort of
hopping on this ml based code completion
thing there's another new paper out of
huawei called pangu coder program
synthesis with function level language
modeling this is a system based on the
pangu alpha architecture which is a
chinese large language model and is much
like codex fine-tuned on code now there
are a few notable differences for
example this paper focuses on solving
the human eval data set challenge in the
end which is a python challenge where
you get a description of what a function
should do and then you should generate
that function you also get a bunch of
unit tests it is kinda like stuff that
we've seen before but it's also
different the architecture here is
nothing special it is a decoder only
language model that is first trained on
on just source code in general and then
fine-tuned more and more towards this
challenge one interesting thing is that
as they progress they pay attention to
the quality of data which seems to be
quite important in these code completion
models so they verify the abstract
syntax tree of python files and then as
an intermediate step before they
actually go to the data set which is
remember human descriptions plus the
function body that you're supposed to
generate they do take the doc strings of
functions that are of appropriate length
as an intermediate like as a proxy task
so they view the docs string as the
description and then they generate the
function body from that seems pretty
straightforward and obviously uh there
is lots of suspicions that things like
copilot are training at least in part on
similar things now they do have a bunch
of other improvements and technical
nuances over which i don't want to go in
here but all of this results in models
that are smaller than other code
generation or other coding competition
models yet improve upon their
performance which is pretty cool so if
you're interested check out the paper
i'll link it in the description
[Music]
and just a few helpful things for this
week quaterion is a blazing fast
framework for fine-tuning similarity
learning models so the specific focus
here is on fine-tuning these models in a
very fast and data efficient way with
small data i should say potentially
small data obviously you can use large
data but it is possible with small data
this is built on top of pi torch
lightning so it's quite accessible and
user friendly torch dim is a project out
of pi torch it's in preview but it
introduces named tensors so name tensors
are a concept of first class dimensions
in tensors and things like pi torch now
the idea here is that instead of you
having to remember that the first
dimension is the batch dimension and
then always address with a zero and just
keep that in mind is that you address
dimensions specifically so this
introduces a dim type a type four
dimension for example batch and then you
can simply use that batch dimension in
order to index tensors this isn't a
speed up in runtime or anything like
this it just makes code a whole lot more
reasonable and a lot less prone to error
the mosaic ml composer library now has
automated gradient accumulation so they
claim that composer lets users
seamlessly change gpu types and number
of gpus without having to worry about
batch size kudo out of memory errors are
a thing of the past i'm not going to
believe that i'm sorry even if you solve
every single problem that we know of
huda out of memory errors will stay with
us until the eventual downfall of
civilization in the year 2089. but apart
from that with the trainer of composer
you can simply tell it to gradient
accumulate automatically gradient
accumulation is a concept where you
don't pass the full mini batch you only
pass part of it which i guess is then
called a mini mini batch so the full
mini batch if you wanted to run it you'd
propagate it and computing the gradient
would blow your memory because you're
training a transformer that's just too
big for your gpu at that batch size so
you can propagate just you know a few
samples or even one sample you can
propagate it and then essentially store
those gradients and propagate the next
thing and then accumulate those
gradients in place until you've passed
the entire mini batch and only at the
end of passing all the individual
samples or subparts you will then do the
gradient update step to your weights
this is a known trick so essentially
your training behaves as if you were to
use the large batch size and we know
that large batch sizes are important for
some of the current models especially
the large ones so it behaves like you
train with a large batch size but you
can run it on hardware that can only
handle a smaller batch size now the
trade-off here is time so you use the
amount of forward passes in time that
you split your mini batch into but it's
better than not being able to run it at
all and this library does it
automatically and lastly mmap ninja will
store your training files as memory map
files which makes training iteration or
evaluation any sort of iteration over
these files a lot faster so here the
readme says when do i use it use it
whenever you want to store a sequence of
numpy arrays of varying shapes that you
are going to read from at random
positions very often so the problem here
is that if you have a file on disk with
a lot of stuff in it and you want to
read at random positions then very often
the operating system makes you scan that
file either from the beginning or from
some intermediate large chunk barrier
and that can be very cumbersome so
memory mapping is a way of speeding that
up and this library handles it
transparently for you all right that was
already it for this episode of ml news
let me know what you think about ai
models that code and everything else in
the world as always stay hydrated bye
[Music]